das hier ist der einzig wahre Caesar
Salad und um den zu machen brauchst du
ein bisschen Ausdauer
aber es lohnt sich kümmern wir uns
zunächst um unsere Croutons für die
selfmade Optik halbiere ich ein Ciabatta
schon feine Streifen darüber gebe ich
jetzt ein bisschen Olivenöl wir machen
extra bread Sticks und nicht diese
kleinen Würfel für den selfmade Touch
jetzt haben wir aus dem Knoblauch eine
Paste hergestellt und machen das gleiche
mit drei Sardellen wenn wir diese Paste
fertig haben gebe ich Ihnen eine große
Schüssel zusammen mit einem Eigelb dazu
ein Teelöffel Senf den Saft einer
Zitrone und etwas westlicher Soße jetzt
gehen wir nach und nach dem neutrales
Pflanzenöl rein um das ganze zu
emotionieren dazu kommt jetzt ein
bisschen schwarzer Pfeffer und Parmesan
Käse fertig ist das Dressing dazu mache
ich eine Hähnchenbrust bisschen Olivenöl
drüber ein paar Kräuter Salz und Pfeffer
und die Braten jetzt goldbraun bei
unserem Romanasalat schneide ich den
Strunk ab und schneidet dann so 5 cm
breite Streifen runter und jetzt heben
wir das Ganze einmal schön durch jetzt
gehen wir unseren Salat auf einen Teller
schicken gebe ich drüber das gebe ich
Platz an die Seite und zu guter Letzt
parmesanhobel und fertig ist er